I always understood that there really
was no difference between me and the
audience at times I might have had
better shoes but at the core of what
really matters that we are the same you
know how I know that because all of us
are seeking the same thing we'll go out
into the world and each pursue based
upon what you believe your talents are
what your skills are maybe your gifts
are but you're seeking the same thing
everybody wants to fulfill the highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being that's what you're looking for the
highest truest expression of yourself as
a human being and because I understand
that I understand that if you're working
in a bakery and that's where you want to
be that may be what you've always wanted
to do is to bake pies for people or bake
cakes for people or to offer your gift
then that's for you and there's no
difference between you and me except
that's how that's your platform that's
your show every day so my understanding
of that has allowed me to reach everyone
and and there's no way that you wouldn't
because that's that's what I truly feel
a lot of people don't know their purpose
and if you don't know your purpose your
immediate goal is to figure that out
because otherwise you're just wandering
around here so the moment you can figure
out what it is you're supposed to be
doing
the sooner you are able to get about the
business of doing that you just watch
two amazing clips from Oprah Winfrey
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]